the first time I heard about the idea
for us to design a car for gt6 she
didn't quite believe it at the same time
I thought it was pretty a pretty amazing
opportunity for us BMW S stands for
sheer driving pleasure and this fits
very much to operation Gran Turismo
package and I in the co Gran Turismo
need Chirac select a drama Taylor
Strategos to go in this man so many
energy God and a grandes Matsushita
brand started circuit auto - me as you
know we do concept cars but we rarely do
concept cars that can drive you know
full-on like they do in the virtual
world
gt6 that's pretty much
once-in-a-lifetime opportunity our
engineers on the one side and on the
other side our designers worked very
hard to several months the design
process behind this car is similar to
what we usually do but maybe in a much
more compact version if you will
everything we did aerodynamic functions
as well as all the other technical
functions are not just a design issue it
has to work really well I mean it's
designed and conceived engineered
actually to race engineered in the
virtual world but engineered to race and
win
communication GT car Madhubala BMW
Rasika to youto muzzle contact on
Assizes retro-modern go no hurry - de la
vivienda book she litter boxia no
question there the magento a modern day
era control I'm a high-tech like when
you look at the car you'll see typical
BMW proportions with a short front
overhanging the longer the rearward
cabin but all of that in an extreme
package basically super low super wide
so the first impact in this car is gonna
be just like pure BMW racing feelings
you will see as well some typical BMW
icons the kidneys
that double round headlamps the l-shaped
tail lamps the Hofmeister king all of
that are things that you find our
production cars and you will find on
that car as well it's this red thread
that goes through every BMW that is
essential to what we do this car is pure
BMW sportiness pure BMW dynamics
it's a precise driving machine that just
looks the part and actually drives
exactly the way you expect the BMW to
drive
you